30 ans après Jurassic Park on rêve
toujours de recréer les dinosaures vous
pensez que ce n'est qu'un fantasme
détrompez-vous vous caresserez peut-être
un raptor de votre vivant faire renaître
les dinosaures en inversant l'évolution
en 2011 Jack Horner paléontologue
américain et consultant des films
Jurassic Park s'est lancé dans le projet
food recréer des Dino depuis le poulet
c'est logique et les oiseaux sont des
avions les derniers représentants de la
classe des dinosaures donc en théorie
pas besoin de les faire renaître ils
existent toujours nous on veut retrouver
ce disparu il y a 66 millions d'années
les dinosaures Noah vient avec des dents
quatre pattes et une queue tirex
diplodocus et tricératops il y a du
choix parmi leurs 160 millions d'années
d'existence contrairement aux films
l'idée est de retrouver leur ADN dans
celui des poulets actuels parce que dans
notre ADN il y a nos gènes mais il peut
aussi rester celui de nos ancêtres
regarde les humains vous pouvez naître
couvert de poils avec une queue ou
plusieurs tétons comme nos ancêtres
mammifères on appelle ça la tavisme la
réactivation d'un gène ancestrale Horner
et son équipe se concentrent sur la
réapparition des dents de la queue et la
transformation des ailes en bras
l'objectif passer d'un poulet à un
chickenosaurus deux ans plus tard on en
est où en 2015 les deux gènes
responsables du développement d'un
museau et des dents sont identifiés et
réactivés ça commence bien mais ça reste
bancal le bec ne se développe pas mais
la petite pellicule de peau sur le bec
si vraiment gênant pour manger pour les
dents c'est pas fou elles sont
totalement inutiles impossible de
réactiver le gène de l'émail parce qu'il
a disparu du génome de la poule le
Checker desaurus est donc condamné à
avoir des dents en carton lors d'une
interview fin 2022 orner a confié qu'à
76 ans il envisage de prendre sa
retraite mais son équipe travaille
toujours sur le projet en 2020 il
étudier le développement de la colonne
vertébrale pour les différents groupes
d'oiseaux et cette année ils ont
découvert comment la queue du Raptor a
évolué en fait pour faire réapparaître
la queue c'est pas un gène qu'il faut
réactiver l'embryon de poulet au début
il a une queue c'est suite à une
inflammation pendant son développement
que les quatre vertèbres de la queue se
soudent entre elles donne une sorte de
coccyx le pigostyle alors hop avec un
petit peu d'anti-inflammatoire au bon
moment on obtient une queue de Raptor ça
paraît un peu facile mais en évolution
il suffit d'une seule mutation au bon
endroit pour tout changer bidouiller les
embryons de poulet c'est pas uniquement
le terrain de jeu de Jack Horner et de
son équipe sans prétention de ramener
les dinos les chercheurs du Laboratoire
de l'évolution naturelle et artificielle
à l'Université de Genève on découvert
cette année comment transformer les
écailles de poulet en plumes cette
fois-ci c'est bien un gène à réactiver
en injectant une solution de contrôle au
bon endroit et au bon moment du
développement de l'embryon d'ailleurs
ils ont appelé ce gène Sonic et jog oui
oui c'est Sonic l'hérisson en anglais
malheureusement toutes ces expériences
ont réalisées sur des embryons de poulet
qui vont grandir dans leur œuf sans
jamais pouvoir éclore vous ne caresserez
jamais un check-inosaurus mais pourquoi
la réponse de Horner n'est pas très
claire il prétendent qu'ils ne veulent
tout simplement pas de couler bizarre
dans la nature mais est-ce que c'est la
vraie raison lorsqu'on manipule
génétiquement des embryons surtout aussi
radicalement ils peuvent tout simplement
ne plus être viable et mourir avant
c'est l'explication la plus simple mais
enjeux sont trop importants pour
l'avouer il risque de perdre leur
financement tant qu'on n'a pas la preuve
que ça ne marche pas on peut toujours
vendre du rêve la deuxième raison c'est
les lois bioéthiques aux États-Unis
c'est bien moins strict qu'en France
là-bas on mange des OGM du soja du maïs
mais aussi du saumon la coabondage
Salmon et le premier animal
génétiquement modifié autorisé à la
consommation depuis 2015 c'est un saumon
de l'Atlantique auquel on a ajouté l'ADN
de morue et de son mont Royal pour qu'il
grandisse plus vite et ça marche il
atteint sa taille adulte deux fois plus
vite qu'un saumon non modifié alors
pourquoi ne pas modifier de poulet pour
créer ce saumon il a fallu obtenir
l'autorisation d'organismes fédéraux et
prouvé qu'il ne représente aucun danger
pour l'homme ou l'environnement qui les
stables génétiquement et que les
modifications ne causeront ni problème
de santé ni souffrance animale ça
correspond notre poulet changer
radicalement son bec et son squelette
impactera sa façon de s'alimenter et son
équilibre les changements sont trop
importants pour prouver qu'il n'en
souffrira pas et sans cette certitude
les organismes fédéraux n'autoriseront
jamais de le faire naître et en réalité
le chickenosaurus ça ne reste qu'un
poulet désormais alors oui d'extérieur
il ressemblera un raptor tel qu'on
s'imagine mais pour tout le reste on n'a
aucune idée de comment c'était du
fonctionnement de ces organes à son
comportement ce qu'on connaît grâce aux
fossiles et limité impossible de
modifier le poulet pour que ça
correspondent on ne pourra pas faire
renaître à Dino disparu il y a 66
millions d'années avec cette méthode
terre renaître les dinosaures grâce au
clonage dans les années 2000 la première
idée était de les cloner en utilisant la
radn comme dans Jurassic Park sauf que
cette méthode présentée deux grosses
difficultés on n'avait pas d'ADN et on
ne savait pas que le nez entre espèces
depuis 2011 on a retrouvé un résidu de
sang dans un moustique conservé dans
l'ambre et même mieux que ça des tissus
mous avec des vaisseaux sanguins des
bouts de protéines de globules rouges ou
de collagène des échantillons
exceptionnels mais dont on n'avait pas
réussi à extraire d'ADN aujourd'hui la
science était des solutions l'adna lui
seul est un gros morceau du problème on
a besoin du génome entier d'une espèce
pour la cloner normalement la
reproduction c'est un ovaire et un
spermatozoïde chacun apporte 50% du
génome pour le clonage il nous faut un
ovaire dont on remplace le noyau par
celui d'une cellules contenant le génome
entier de l'espèce à clonée sur le
papier c'est facile on sait le faire
depuis 1996 avec Dolly première brebis
clonée après il y en a beaucoup d'autres
des chats des lapins des chevaux des
rats mais aucun oiseau et c'est un
problème parce que le plan serait d'en
utiliser un comme mère porteuse vu que
bah c'est des dinosaures le choix le
plus économique serait d'utiliser la
poule une espèce qu'on connaît bien pas
cher et le temps d'incubation d'un œuf
est rapide alors pourquoi on ne le fait
pas le premier problème c'est le jaune
d’œuf à l'intérieur il y a le noyau de
l'ovule à remplacer et il est vraiment
mais vraiment minuscule c'est comme
chercher une aiguille dans une botte de
foin et le jaune c'est bien trop gros
pour être observé au microscope deuxième
problème le reste de l’œuf une fois le
jeu n'expulsé de l’ovaire de la poule il
est ensuite recouvert du blanc d'une
membrane puis de la coquille difficile
d'intervenir entre ces étapes à
l'intérieur de la poule pour les
mammifères c'est bien plus simple on
implante l'embryon dans l'utérus de la
mer porteuse et le tour est joué cloner
des poules c'est donc Mission Impossible
enfin avec cette méthode depuis deux ans
des chercheurs
mais on a toujours le même problème pour
faire des chimères il faut des cellules
germinales de Dino il faut pas rêver
c'est tellement spécifique qu'on n'est
pas prêt d'en retrouver heureusement ce
n'est pas l'unique possibilité ça
marcherait aussi avec n'importe quel
cellule contenant le génome complet de
l'espèce à cloné en la reprogrammant
c'est lui de Germinal pour ça il
faudrait quelques étapes supplémentaires
mais d'après une étude publiée en 2021
c'est pas impossible pour le dodo ce
n'est plus un si grand obstacle car son
génome complet a été reconstruire en
2022 pour les dinos en revanche on n'a
pas génome complet donc est-ce qu'on est
aussi près du but est-ce qu'il y a moyen
de faire quelque chose des échantillons
qu'on a déjà pour le moment on a des
protéines qui permettraient de retrouver
au maximum 2% du génome aïe pourquoi ne
pas utiliser des génomes de la poule
pour les 98% manquants déjà parce qu'on
ne sait pas identifier quelle partie
sont manquante mais surtout qu'entre le
Raptor et la poule il y a eu 66 millions
d'années d'évolution aujourd'hui leur
génome commun est estimé à seulement 3%
quand on sait que l'homme possède 99% de
son génome en commun avec le chimpanzé
c'est pas avec 2% de Raptor qu'on aura
un résultat concluant donc pas de choix
il faut complet d'un dinosaure en 2012
on découvre que l'ADN contenu ailleurs
que dans le noyau d'une cellule et super
fragile pour des offensiles c'est la
moitié qui est perdue tous les 521 ans
au bout de 1,5 millions d'années il ne
reste plus rien alors espérer retrouver
de l'ADN lieu de 66 millions d'années ou
plus ça paraissait impossible et ça a
vite été abandonné en réalité cette
conclusion dépend beaucoup du contexte
de conservation pendant longtemps on a
cru que les échantillons les mieux
conservés seraient ceux en profondeur
dans la glace à des températures
extrêmement faibles sauf qu'une cellule
en dehors du noyau c'est 80% d'eau donc
en gelant ça prend plus de place et la
cellule explose les meilleures
conditions de conservation seraient
d'être enfouis à l'abri des charognards
et du soleil comme le prouve baby et
clients le fossile d'embryon dinosaure
le mieux préservé au monde un œuf de
Dino vieux de 72 à 66 millions d'années
découvert il y a seulement deux ans
parfaitement conservé grâce à un
glissement debout c'est un super beau
fossile pourtant n'a rien trouvé
d'organiques dedans même pas une petite
protéine lors de la fossilisation les
minéraux pénètrent dans les tissus et
cellules pour les composants organiques
petit à petit même dans les meilleures
conditions retrouvez des traces d'ADN et
extrêmement rare mais certains
scientifiques continuent d'y croire avec
la découverte du fossile le plus
prometteur le cartilage du fémur d'un
codypthérix découvert en 2021 au
nord-est de la Chine un petit Dino
disparu il y a 125 millions d'années
donc bien avant l'extinction tellement
bien conservé qu'on y a retrouvé quelque
chose qui ressemble à un noyau de
cellules oui oui la pièce manquant du
puzzle comment c'est possible le
cartilage se conserve vachement bien
c'est un tissu sans veine donc avec très
peu d'eau en plus il était recouvert de
cendres ça limite la contamination
maintenant vous attendez le moment où je
vous dis que c'est révolutionnaire ou
bien que ça ne marchera pas et bien en
fait on ne sait pas encore si c'est
vraiment un noyau qui a été décelé sur
ce cartilage de Kodi perix et encore
moins s'il contient un génome entier
pour le savoir il faudrait beaucoup de
tests et donc attendre encore quelques
années ce qui laisse le temps de
développer les techniques de clonage des
oiseaux et aussi de se poser les
questions éthiques ramenées parmi nous
les dinos les espèces disparues ça fait
rêver et ça paraît même qu'on sait que
la moitié de la biomasse a disparu
depuis l'apparition de l'homme sur terre
mais est-ce que ça justifie vraiment la
réintroduction de prédateurs pour
d'autres espèces animales et végétales
qui bouleverseront les écosystèmes
actuels en plus rien ne garantit que
faire revenir une espèce disparue soit
vraiment viable sur le long terme pour
celles et teinte récemment leur habitat
naturel existe peut-être encore elle
pourrait survivre à l'état sauvage mais
rien n'est garanti non seulement
l'écosystème où elle vivait à évolué
sans elle mais pour qu'elle ait une
chance de survie il faudrait
réintroduire une population entière sauf
que la première génération n'aura pas de
parents sera élevé en captivité et ne
transmettra jamais à la suivante comment
survivre dans la nature comptez
uniquement sur un instinct primaire est
un pari très risqué pour les espèces
disparues il y a des dizaines centaines
voire millions d'années tout a changé
les animaux plantes qu'elles mangés le
climat voire même la composition de
l'air et c'est sans compter les
bactéries microbes et virus qui ont
évolué depuis et ça c'est dans le cas où
l'on amène exactement l'espèce disparue
et non une version clonée ou modifiée
génétiquement ces animaux ont une santé
fragile et ont besoin d'un suivi leur
réintroduction en milieu élevage n’est
donc pas envisageable alors si par
miracle on est arrivé à faire naître un
clone de Kodi Terry ça à partir de
l'unique potentielle noyau de cellules
retrouvées jusqu'à maintenant dans le
meilleur des cas il ne surgrivera que
quelques temps dans un laboratoire mais
au moins il aura financé la recherche
Jack Horner le dit lui-même le projet
chickenosaurus c'était une première avec
son équipe ils sont partis de rien et on
fait de grandes découvertes sur la
génétique et l'évolution des dinosaures
aux oiseaux finalement le véritable but
de son projet ça n'a jamais été de faire
renaître les dinosaures mais de faire
avancer la science et pour ça ça vaut le
coup de continuer de rêver avant de vous
laisser je voulais vous remercier depuis
plus de 3 ans la chaîne existe et on
continue de s'approcher du million la
chaîne vit aussi grâce à la
participation d'une grosse équipe de
rédacteurs et monteurs cons salut et
remercie grandement je pars à Montréal
pour une conférence scientifique pendant
deux semaines mais la chaîne elle ne
prend pas de vacances donc continuez à
nous suivre cet été Ciao
[Musique]